good morning millennials welcome back to
the chosen happy Wednesday a gorgeous
hump day here at the toast hey Jax how
you darn I'm doing good is there
anything could a hump day ever be
anything other than garges
I mean it could how
I don't know let's say you get some
really bad news like bad news waits for
nothing you know it's true it's true but
hopefully we're early enough that
anything that's not gorgeous will be
waiting for us in the latter half of the
day you know what's so funny I guess I
like read a book recently that used the
phrase like bad weights bad news waits
for no one and and or nothing or
whatever no
it was in the Summer I Turned Pretty
like bad news can't wait oh yeah because
we called early in the morning with
Susanna's news yes and I have like used
that phrase four times since I heard it
you know it's like in my brain now oh
that's so funny well that's where it's
from interesting
one of the grits I started a new book
last night actually I think you've read
it on a quiet street love love love such
a good thriller like it's amazing I
remember you saying that you didn't like
it no I liked it I feel like there was a
thriller that you read recently where
you said nothing happened the whole time
and I felt like it was on a quiet street
no it might have been the inmate which
is what everybody told me to read
they're like it's Frida's best book you
know we're Freedom McFadden girlies
everyone's like you haven't read the
inmate stunk yeah no it wasn't the
inmate because you read the inmate
recently and you said this like on your
Instagram maybe a month or two ago
whatever I'm glad it's not the book I'm
reading no I don't think it is that's a
really good thriller that's one that's
like having a moment going viral it is
having a moment so I figured I'd see
what all the fuss is about and so how
exciting yeah that's fabulous
um I feel broken like is it just me like
whenever I wear heels like I have sore
legs the next day I think it's because I
have like no muscles so like my legs
literally did a workout from like
carrying the weight of my body yeah I
took half workout for sure yeah I'm
broken I wore heels last night we had
our pickles Spritz um launch event which
was so fun it was such like a gorgeous
Summer Night on a rooftop I'm just
broken like I can't hang like I used to
getting old man
getting older
is not the same it seems to me no like
each day I wake up with a new ailment
like I'm truly like you're breaking I'm
wobbling into old age honestly you're
coming apart at the seams
calm down calm down you need to listen
to your body and take a break not like
run off to Boston without your big sis
the thing is I'm saying yes to life and
saying yes to life waits for nobody and
waits for no thing well I mean it's not
without
it's it's downsides that's drawbacks
like your body is breaking down yeah I
mean I think when you like look at my
Instagram and my social media you're
like oh yes this girl is clearly saying
yes to life it looks fabulous it looks
fun it looks fresh I'm here to tell you
you know on the podcast you get the real
deal totally authentic not highlight
version I'm deeply unwell you guys like
one it's we're halfway through the year
of yes I feel like I have actually
follow through with my New Year's
resolution which was just like saying
yes to life doing more things and I've
actually been doing it and here's my
halfway update like I'm not okay
but you are okay like yes you're really
enjoying but what I was going to say is
maybe you should get a massage today
even if it's just like at the nail salon
a little 10 minute massage
idea yeah or get a pedicure and get your
feet rubbed for like 10 minutes per leg
because they do the five minutes it
comes included
but you could bump it up to 10 per leg
they don't do five per per leg that's
not included they give you like 30
seconds per leg no at my place it's five
per leg
well I can't go to your place because
the last time I was there the girl you
recommended called me gordita because
she thought I didn't speak Spanish but I
do and gordita means little fat
girl so I haven't really felt safe there
so she called you little
actually no gordita roughly translates
to just fat for female fat feet no
that's Gorda the ITA makes it little
gordita translation no it maybe you're
like a young you know it literally is
chubby girl
I guess gorda's a chubby woman Jackie
she thought you were young Jackie does
your arm hurt from reaching it was an
insult listen get over it she does an
amazing mani pedi and she's got hands
like no no one else if you want to get
those legs rubbed no I haven't been able
to enjoy my time there ever since so but
also you need to thank her because
haters have been your motivators
not really yeah really
no I don't think I don't think any part
of me was motivated to like go on my
health Journey
um because of the haters like I don't
care what other people think of me I
hated myself like that I am my biggest
hater I'm the hater that was the
motivator that is fair to say but not
other people okay I just feel like you
should go in there kill so many birds
with one stone one you'll get amazing
massage too call me Gorda again
again because to her it was like an
offhand remark she didn't know that I
heard it like she doesn't even probably
know or remember that she called me
gordita but for me it's like you know we
all have moments in our life where we're
like especially if you like struggled
with your weight where you have heard
other people call you fat or like talk
about your body and literally those
moments you will take them to your grave
with you you will never forget them for
sure but there's no part of you that now
wants to go in there and be like
no because it won't be gratifying she
doesn't know that it was a moment I know
it was a moment but she doesn't know
okay I think you're missing out on what
could be another great moment for you
no no I don't do it for her I do it for
me well then you're definitely missing
out on a great foot rub
yeah no I'll I'll take into
consideration getting a foot rub but I'm
not going to your place like I if I if I
don't do that like I really truly stand
for nothing you know oh my God
as a consumer who disagree as a consumer
like my
um
business is my power you know yeah
and I'm gonna wield my power towards you
know more safe spaces
okay
well we've got a great show for you guys
today it's Wednesday which means we've
got deer toasters we have an update
remember the girly who wrote in and said
you know she went off birth control and
literally everything in her life feels
different she no longer feels attracted
to her partner
um it was kind of a big conversation in
in our community and so she's written in
with an update and I think you'll be
interested to hear what she has to say
I'm so interested because I was so
interested by that story one because
then everyone in the community was like
this happened to me and then we're also
like kind of realizing that maybe like
birth control is like meant to program
us to be attracted to mediocre men and
maybe it's like a patriarchy it's kind
of it's a pill to take to support the
patriarch it's the patriarchy colluding
with big Pharma and we're just putting
the pieces together right so we'll hear
from one of our subjects on the matter
can't wait yeah
um what else is going on oh my episode
of out and about is about today I went
on Joey camasta's podcast like a week
and a half ago and it came out today I
actually watched it this morning before
we got started just you know energize me
on the subject of me and it was fabulous
what'd you guys talk about oh everything
we talked about Cuba Gooding Jr we
talked about Say Yes to the Dress we
talked about orgies it really was a wide
spanning conversation oh nice your
highlight reel literally that's like
when you go out into the world that's
like what people
associate with you with this like Cuba
Gooding Jr say yes today I know I mean I
talked about that on the podcast about
how I hate both of those things and I
would love to stop talking about them
however you know if people are talking
to me I'm just happy I don't care what
it's about they're kind of your claims
to fame I know but like
we know we know and The Toasters know
and like and they show
we don't even discuss no it's old news
so it might be refreshing for people to
hear it if they've never heard the story
right it's true head over to out and
about podcasts
um that's so fun maybe I'll watch that
today yeah it's on YouTube it's on the
tube
um
and what else I feel like I had like
something I needed to say on the toes
like a funny story or something although
I cannot recall maybe it'll come to me
I finished watching the new Roni episode
oh so that I could you know put a lid on
it I didn't think it was good but I
don't think that means that it's gonna
be terrible I didn't think any of the
women like stood out in any sort of
major way they're all kind of very
similar and also playing it safe because
at this point like you know what makes
good reality TV how to be successful on
reality TV but none of them like had a
distinct enough personality except for
Brynn but she's kind of all over the
place like I don't know what she's about
is Bryn like the brunette girl with like
a kind of a pouty face yeah yeah
um I saw I've seen a bunch of clips of
the episode and I don't know if this is
fair to say because I again haven't seen
the entire episode but she like appears
like she's trying so hard yeah she just
like is saying crazy stuff I think
because like that's what plays on TV and
on the one hand it's like okay this
doesn't seem genuine but on the other
hand no one else is really doing
anything so yeah it's good I guess uh
but no it also seems like this group of
women don't really know each other
they're just kind of all like plucked
from all around the five boroughs and
put together in Jenna lines apartment
with the fondue board
yeah that's tough and I think from like
a casting perspective it's really hard
to get like a group of people who know
each other for a long time who all want
to do the show and then who are also all
interesting and wealthy and women of you
know status
um but as a viewer like it's so
frustrating I feel like with a bunch of
the seasons of Housewives like we got to
a place where like you could tell these
women were never hanging out unless they
had to film and it's like not fun like
that history makes it you know high
stakes and makes it interesting yeah and
I just wonder how it worked with the
Lizzie savitsky stuff like did they film
for a few weeks all of that blew up and
then they scrapped all that and started
again it does kind of feel that way
because they're talking about like
dinners and stuff that maybe happened in
the Lizzie era because there's no food
did they not address it no they don't
address it it's not like she's in the
background like when they're in Jenna's
apartment like like she had just the
girls over for a girl's night and like
Lizzy's obviously not there I feel like
it's post Lizzy which actually makes it
a little better because then they had
those weeks of filming hanging out so
they had more opinions about each
further but I'm just curious
yeah I mean that would make sense and I
also think like Bravo probably doesn't
want to open themselves up to any sort
of like lawsuit because there was like
allegations of anti-Semitism and stuff
so to like start with a clean slate I
guess yeah no it would have been really
confusing to come in and try and explain
the drama that happened like we're
trying to get more get to know a new
group of women like
it doesn't make sense or it would have
been confusing to just
use that footage but cut her out right
because then there would be like a big
gaping hole right
interesting I keep saying like I might
watch it but every time I go to like my
clicker like sorry it's me and young
Sheldon till the day I die yeah no what
I've seen so far you don't need to watch
but I'll I'll keep up with like what
people are saying about it if it seems
like it's getting better maybe I'll I'll
give it another shot I just saw the
ratings for it I think it was like 670
000 people
I don't know whether that's good or bad
these days me neither like it doesn't
sound good it doesn't sound good but I
think these days in the Bravo universe
and like cable Universe I think it's
pretty decent
it doesn't sound good and it certainly
doesn't sound good for a premiere of a
new show that's like incredibly hyped up
but Andy said like this might Inspire
them to reboot some other cities
well not if it doesn't go well yeah
what cities do you think need to be
rebooted oh see
apparently OC is like doing well I
actually was thinking about watching
again but there's not that many episodes
out so I didn't want to like get into it
and then have nothing to watch I
actually watched an episode of it
because Brian keeps up with it when we
were the Hamptons he was watching it so
I sat down and watched it with him when
we watched crappy like which again I
can't recommend enough
um
it seemed fine honestly I there was like
this moment where Heather Dubrow like
did like a losery thing which she
doesn't do you know like she was they
were doing Peak and pit of their trip
because they took a trip to Montana and
she was like a pit of mine is just you
know Shannon and Tamara have made up
after all these years and she feels like
you know they were leaving her out and
like they weren't and she like started
crying and they're like what are you
doing like it was so not Heather Dubrow
like not you know she's like fancy Queen
it was not it was so like losery of her
that's weird yeah no it felt weird it
felt like everyone was like doing the
most I know there's like a new housewife
um and there's like some tea on her and
Tamara have has of course you know found
it and is exploiting it
um I don't know if they need a reboot
but Emily my queen Emily wasn't on the
trip because she got kovid um so the
episode wasn't as good as it could have
been
interesting I don't really need any
cities to be rebooted I feel like I'm
just moving away from watching like so
much housewives that unless they are in
a city and like with people who I
already care about I don't plan on
watching it but that's why I watch
Ronnie because like we're New Yorkers
I'm Gonna Give You shots but it's also
fun to just watch New York be portrayed
as like fabulous and where are they
going yeah
yeah but it also feels like something
about it it feels so like 10 years ago
in the way that they're like talking
about New York almost I can't explain
like it feels like this was the pilot
that was shot alongside the original
pilot interesting talking about New York
like New York has really changed and I
just don't feel like that they've
reflected in the show oh that's
interesting
I can't explain it and it doesn't make a
super New Yorkie it's just like everyone
maybe because we're only in people's
Apartments so far I've only been in
apartment right and they're nice which
is interesting you would like the
apartments and they live oh most of them
live either like downtown or Brooklyn I
don't think anyone lives Uptown not that
I've seen that well no I mean the whole
original show took place Uptown when
there was a housewife who lived downtown
it was like the biggest deal I know
oh that's interesting I do like to see
part of for me the Allure of the show is
seeing people's like homes cars their
wealth
um and that's why I think that OG show
got so boring because it really wasn't
like this group of fabulous rich women
it was this group of like alcoholic
women who are no longer women of stature
yeah who are like they're four stars
right they're like former Morgan erises
they're former countesses and like that
doesn't really pay the bills yeah no the
things that pay the bills are just like
not the things that we want to see them
doing no they're professional reality
stars now they're honestly on the same
Financial level as like you know the
Vanderpump Rules kids who were waiters
and waitresses
right who are now professional reality
stars it's like the same you know tax
bracket yeah
okay interesting well
um we've got a great show I think we
should dive in we've got some stories
and we've got your toasters and I'm
excited about it okay let's get into the
fast five stories that you need to know
and the first time stories that you need
to know are brought to you by eBay
authenticity guarantee Jackie and I love
to invest whether it's in purses
clothing shoes we are always making sure
to shop smart with eBay authenticity
guarantee eBay authenticators are there
verifying every detail of your purchase
so basically the eBay authenticity
guarantee protects buyers from fakes and
it gives them the assurance that they're
getting the real deal because you know
sometimes shopping on the internet when
you're looking for the real deal it can
feel like the wild wild west but eBay's
out here to protect you because what is
worse than spending time money energy
scouring researching the internet for
your next purchase only to later find
out that you have been scammed with eBay
authenticity guarantee you'll never get
faked over again their service currently
covers eligible items across sneakers
watches handbags jewelry and streetwear
we feel more confident in ordering
online knowing that an expert at eBay is
authenticating our items so any purchase
backed by the authenticity guarantee is
sent to the authentication team who
personally inspect the item check it
against the sting and authenticate it so
in a world full of fakes it's time to
get real with eBay authenticity
guarantee eBay is such an amazing
platform whether you're looking for you
know something vintage something rare
and I feel like a lot of people spend a
lot of time scouring eBay for that one
particular item and now with the
authentic authenticity guarantee it's
just Peace of Mind knowing that eBay is
going to handle all the stress so ensure
your next purchase is the real deal with
eBay authenticity guarantee everyone
deserves real visit ebay.com for terms
today's episode is also brought to you
by game time buying tickets to your
favorite events should not be stressful
game time is the fast and easy way to
buy tickets for all the sports music
comedy and theater near you so if you're
looking for the spring musical make sure
to get your tickets on the game time app
they have killer deals on last minute
tickets and their best price guarantee
you can stop stressing over the tickets
and start getting hyped for the fun
you're gonna have game time is the place
for last minute tickets so forget
planning months in advance game time has
deals on tickets right up to the day of
the event get exclusive Flash Deals on
tickets for football basketball baseball
concerts comedy theater and more the
game time guarantee also means you'll
always get the best price so if you find
tickets in the same section and the same
Row for Less you will get credited by
game time for 110 of the difference
you're getting images of your seats
before you buy you know exactly what to
expect when you arrive and you can buy
tickets in a matter of seconds so you
just tap and you're set tickets are then
sent directly to your phone so you never
have to dig through your email or Worse
print
um game time is a great app to just have
on your phone if you live in a fabulous
City like New York with lots of things
going on if you travel a lot and you're
always looking for different things to
do in the cities that you're in whether
it be for work or for pleasure just have
the game time app on your phone you know
you find yourself in Charlotte bring up
the game time app see what the Bobcats
are up to you know see what the local
theater is is showing snag the tickets
without the stress with Game Time
download the game time app create an
account and use code toast for 20 off
your first purchase terms apply again
create an account and redeem code toast
for 20 off download game time today last
minute tickets lowest price guaranteed
awesome thank you are you ready for our
first story awesome oh wow like totally
freaked me out I mean right on
the Toro Sharon number one you know who
else is number one
me
not today
damn the golden Bachelor oh yes the
golden Batcher Jerry Turner is taking
the country by storm so ABC announced
Jerry Turner is ready to find the new
love of his life the 71 year old was
announced as the star of ABC's new
Bachelor spin-off the golden bachelor in
July 2023. according to the network the
father of two is a hopeless romantic
looking for someone to share the sunset
years of life he said it's never too
late to fall in love again don't give up
there's always possibilities he said he
was pushed to join the show by his two
daughters after their mother passed away
though the pressure could make any man
nervous he told GMA that being the first
elderly man to lead the show feels
amazing and it's still sinking in so we
talked about the fact that the bachelor
was doing a spin-off called the Golden
Bachelor we thought it was a golden idea
and now they have found like the perfect
man to lead the show so I think you know
when they first announced the idea
people were you know questioning maybe a
little curious but now that a lot of the
assets have come out and we've seen what
this man looks like when they said
golden Bachelor like I was thinking more
like you know nursing home Vibes like
really old I didn't think of like this
kind of Silver Fox I mean I think we can
all agree this man is extremely hot like
they did an amazing job with casting and
seeing you know his his footage you know
his little commercial like is making me
excited yeah a lot of people excited I
think a lot of fans of the bachelor are
like texting their parents signing their
parents yeah being like you have to go
on I think everybody wants to date this
man I agree I think you probably would
have expected it to be a little more
like what's that actor's name who plays
professor professor John Sturgis on
young child yeah uh Blair waldorf's uh
mom's boyfriend yeah what is his name is
um Mr geis from Clueless right what is
his name
his name is Miss no Miss Geist and
what's what's his name in Clueless Mr in
Clueless oh Mr Hall Mr Hall
Wallace Sean which I didn't perfect
that's he's such a Wallace honestly I
would have loved for him to be the
golden Bachelor too but instead we have
this hot 71 year old who's like we have
this hot piece of ass like who's ready
to find a partner to golf with play
Pickleball with he's a retired
restaurateur with many hobbies and I
think the fact that he's a widower
endears him to a lot of people yeah it's
not like he's you know had three
marriages like I think right I think
they were very
specific about who they wanted to cast I
think they wanted obviously someone
actually old you know not like yeah in
their 50s so like 70s is you know is
pretty old but like good looking
sprightly carry a show because it's
still The Bachelor and they care about
looks and someone whose story would be
like heartwarming too and they found the
perfect man honestly I think AI
generated him no by the way he's giving
AI generated like he's quite literally
perfect
um of course like ABC had to do they're
like annoying
um
like marketing around it I find Bachelor
marketing to be like so lame they're
like his DMS require postage like so
cringe but I do feel like I will give
this show a chance it is extremely cute
it's giving young Sheldon Vibes like
just heartwarming endearing
family-friendly fun I know but I'm just
curious like who this man actually is
looking to be with like and what ages of
the women there's gonna be because I
feel like he could go with a younger
woman like this is like he looks very
young he doesn't look seven day yeah
this is a spirited young Soul it seems
yeah I feel like he needs like a 60 year
old like Nancy Myers Vibe like kind of
Meryl Streep's character from it's
complicated
she's also a restaurateur I feel like
they'll cast women in their 50s too
I mean that's like a huge age Gap I know
it feels different when it's like a 50
year old than a seven-year-old but that
is like a big gap yeah but
I don't know I just I'm really curious
how this is gonna play out
no and I think this is like a big moment
for The Bachelor franchise I mean in the
last few years due to their own just
like
the show never really evolved they had
like a Litany of scandals and just like
other streaming services and networks
like coming up with better ideas for
dating shows like they've really dropped
the ball from like once being the
biggest cultural phenomenon of our time
um and I didn't know what or if they
could do to like get themselves back in
the Zeitgeist and I wouldn't have
expected this but it really is taking
I've been seeing it all over the
Internet it's taking the community by
storm yeah it's really really good move
for them and I feel like the fact that
it's going to be on cable like once a
week it could be the thing that like
unites the nation like I think everyone
will be watching everyone will be
talking about like the women and I also
think it's really nice because we live
in a world that's obsessed with like
youth use and we need to get our
priorities in order and respect our
elders and I think that the golden
Bachelor is inadvertently going to
achieve that you know what it's so funny
because like I feel like The Bachelor
was one of those like toxic shows that
really focused on Youth and like they
were always you know the the crop of
girlies were always the same same you
know blonde young girls and now for them
to use their platform to kind of shine a
light on the elderly and like you know
more mature women I love that yeah I
really like I don't think they're doing
it intentionally they're just trying to
come up with show ideas but I actually
think this is a really wholesome nice
message for the country and they're kind
of going back to their roots in the
sense that when the chauffeurs began
like the the leads the Bachelor and the
bachelorettes like we're actual
Bachelors like they were people who you
know a lot of women would be you know
searching for and then they got to a
point where it was just like kind of
recycling like reality stars and that's
not considered like a you know it's not
like this eligible bachelor but this guy
like is actually probably extremely
sought after you know yes yeah he's an
actual Bachelor yeah I feel like unless
it was someone I mean this is not a
great example but like Colton who's like
a football player and it's right you
have the opportunity to like go on
Colton season yes an NFL player most of
the
now Bachelors are just realities like
they're just like guys they're like
former real estate agents turned
full-time reality stars guy with a
million Instagram followers yeah yeah I
wonder so Jerry has an Instagram
oh we should watch his follower count
that's a really good way to know like if
the show's having an impact once it
starts airing but I don't think it's no
it's not analogous because this the his
demo it's so true is not on Instagram
and I don't believe the show was started
filming it I think they announced him as
the the guy to encourage you know people
of that age demographic to it to apply
and it's gonna work yes I think
everybody who loves The Bachelor or who
like follows pop culture is signing
their parents up well they're moms up
and yeah
maybe a couple married women will show
up and say I saw Jerry's he's I'm
willing to risk it all and I think we
can have a connection I like that
it's really beautiful uh it's street
it's on this fall on Hulu
nabc sorry oh look at us being so
positive I know but this is worth worthy
I think this took everyone
by surprise yeah
yeah
okay our next story page six is
reporting exclusively that Prince Harry
and Meghan Markle are having trouble in
Paradise
um the rumors are swirling that Prince
Harry and Meghan markle's marriage is on
the Rocks Radar Online reported Tuesday
that the Duke and Duchess of Sussex are
taking time apart to heal and rebuild
their bond they're trying to figure out
what hit them Harry doesn't fit in
Megan's tacky Tinseltown World
adding that he's hoping to quote find
himself so that's what radar land
reported but an Insider close to the
couple assures page six that any
speculation of a breakup is untrue The
Insider said quote it's not true it's
literally made up
okay by the way like there's definitely
you know
radar online and Page Six like it's
giving tabloid you know tabula rasa but
I think you know an interesting
conversation is like let's say
hypothetically this is true like they're
making their way they can't like they
literally that's what we've been saying
they couldn't
they're literally forbidden even if they
chose to live separately in in different
houses different bedrooms for the rest
of their lives they cannot divorce no
it's not an option for them it's not my
prediction is that they won't divorce
you know what it's so funny he wanted to
get so far away from like Royal life but
if he's wound up in the same situation
where it's like you can't get a divorce
bro no it's so true and I don't think
that this story is true I think like
if it's it's you know it's not crazy to
think like they've had you know a very
stressful few years like I'm sure you
know they fight like any couple I don't
I really can't see a world in which
they're not making this work they really
all they have is each other
I think their relationship has probably
seen better days like I think things
aren't amazing right now and especially
as amazing as they were when they left
the family and they had each other and
they had so much support and they had
all this opportunity on the horizon like
as we've reported over the last few
weeks and months like a lot of those
things have gone away and I think
public opinion about them has swayed a
little bit so I don't think they're like
doing the best they've ever been but
they're not getting divorced they
literally can't and they're just gonna
deal with it no make it work make it
work he's planning on going to Africa
for a new Netflix documentary because he
the radar Source says it he feels most
like himself while on the continent when
she he considers his second home
what's his first home
damn Montecito
or no where do they live yeah
it's a good question he's kind of
nomadic yeah like what is he consider
his first home oh no what does he
consider his country you know
yeah I'm sure he would say his home is
wherever Megan is and his family and and
I'm sure if he had to ask like gun to
his head what country he like belongs to
the UK
because they really do love him so then
the place where he lives is actually his
third home
listen he's a man of me and he's got
many homes
no like emotionally
wherever Megan is yeah so that's his
first home I don't believe that this
story has any Merit because it literally
cannot
it can't yeah and I just I rebuke yeah
but no I think it has Merit in the sense
that like they're probably
not in the best place they've ever been
while they figure out like what's next
for them yeah they're kind of in this
like transitional period like they kind
of got settled here
and you know before that she was in
Canada it was like a very transitional
period it was very high stakes they got
here they got settled they started
working they became you know Real
Americans and I think between the book
and some of the news like I think it's
really shaken up their their world and
they're no longer feeling you know
stable yeah no and there was so much
promise it had like there was so much
change happening at once so it doesn't
like allow you to really like process
stuff and there was so much promise and
now the the chips have fallen where
they've Fallen they don't think they've
Fallen exactly where that they had hoped
yeah that's that's a good way of putting
it
so I think they'll be together forever
but you know maybe he is sleeping in a
different bedroom maybe it's mandatory
like they are together forever do mois
posted a tip that they had sold their
house and that Harry was living in
another place
oh
yeah
I mean you have to take you have to take
everything you know with a grain of salt
from like blind to gossip
um but that's interesting what do we
know if they're household that's like
all public record that's what I was
gonna say
we would know yeah there would be
pictures of it everywhere we would know
who bought it yeah yeah it would be
Harry and Megan's house for sale and
then a little like 3D tour yeah 3D tour
and then like a blurb on like which
billionaire or other celebrity bought it
because that's like the most interesting
real estate news when like celebrities
and rich people sell their house to
other celebrities and rich people yeah
yeah so we would know that we would know
that or maybe it's like the sales maybe
it's still in escrow
um maybe it's still an escrow I don't
know
but
wishing them well truly wishing them
well
are you ready for our next story a
little more relationship news
BB rexha put her boyfriend Keen Safari
on blast for shaming her about her
weight so Bebe Rex appeared to put her
boyfriend on blast for criticizing her
weight when she shared a screenshot and
of alleged text he sent her the singer
took to her Instagram story to post the
message which hinted at trouble in
Paradise after he allegedly wrote that
he wanted to be honest about her looks
so she posted the screenshot of the text
it's a really long text okay but to be
fair like because we're going to talk
about this in depth I think we need to
read the whole text because
it's it's a very interesting text
message yes it's a very long text
message and it's uh you know I guess the
headline does capture technically what
it says but there it's more layered than
that it's more nuanced than that the you
know takeaway if you're just like giving
General points and these headlines makes
it seem like he called her fat we're out
of nowhere
he said hey I never said you weren't
beautiful and I never said I didn't love
you in fact I said how beautiful you are
and how much I loved you but I always
said I would be honest with you and your
face was changing so I told you it was
that was the conversation we were having
and you asked because I care would you
rather I lied to you you gained 35
pounds obviously you gained weight and
your face changes should I just pretend
it didn't happen and that it's okay come
on I gained three pounds and you call me
chubs in fact doesn't mean you don't
love me if you're trying to find reasons
to break up this makes sense but it's
not the real reason if you're unhappy
with me slash yourself slash with life
and don't see a future with us then
that's okay and that's the reason don't
use something like that to weaponize
your anger or anxiety or any insecurity
you may have you know I always found you
to be beautiful and loved you no matter
what I think it's important for you to
think about things and write things down
speak to a therapist and do this retreat
thing to get to the root of the problem
let me know if you'd like to speak
if you need more clarity love you
so I mean I think everyone's like first
initial reaction it's like this
guy like what a don't talk
about but then when you read the text it
does seem like you know weight is
something that they speak about a lot
because he said you asked and he said
you know you're always telling me when I
gain weight so it seems like it's a
topic of conversation and I think like
in a relationship either you talk about
it or you don't I come from a
relationship where we talk very openly
about it I will ask like do I look fat
do I look like I'd gain weight what do
you think about my stomach and Ben will
be like oh my God does my stomach look
like we we talk about it
um and it feels like a safe space to do
that I don't feel like I'm ever being
judged and I don't feel like I'm ever
being judgy I'm just like we talk about
it matter-of-factly like but do you care
does it bother you do you want like we
talk about it and I think in like a
logical way
um so it seems like they talk about it
because he literally said you asked and
you said something about me so knowing
that I feel like
um
he actually sounds like he's being kind
of kind in a weird way he's trying to
just have a conversation with her she
had spoken recently about how she had
gained um a lot of weight I think she
had said 35 pounds and sometimes like
that's just you know you're living life
and you're that's cool sometimes
sometimes it's a sign of happiness and
contentment sometimes it's not sometimes
it's not and so I feel like he's one she
asked him two he's like there's clearly
something beneath the surface between
the two of them where maybe she's not in
the best place like she's going to a
retreat he's telling her to speak to a
therapist like I think he's trying to
speak to her as kindly as he possible
possibly can seeing this text out of
context like yeah it's like a man should
never comment on a woman's weight but
like they're in a relationship she asked
it's clearly a point of conversation
between the two of them my biggest
question is why did she post this she
deleted it pretty soon after yeah but I
almost feel like it was an accident that
she posted this I know because if she
was trying to make a point
to I feel like we had this conversation
with Sarah Brady like to post
conversation screenshots that like you
are screenshotting what you want to show
is always gonna you know be biased and
CR like you're only showing people what
you want them to see and so for her to
do that and then I think a lot of people
didn't respond in the way that she
thought that they would because of
course like we said our initial reaction
is always like literally don't
talk about my body I'll slit your throat
yeah but it's such a long text message
and it weirdly gives a lot of context
about their relationship so I think once
upon reading it everybody was like wait
it's not that bad yeah and also like why
are you bringing the public into your
current relationship like with the Sarah
Brady thing I could say a year later she
obviously is pissed yeah but this is
like your relationship and it feels like
such a weird way to like it's such a
weird tool in your fighting toolkit to
be like I'm gonna put your text on my
Instagram
no it's definitely this was a weird way
for me to find out Bebe Rex I had a
boyfriend
true if she still has one but again this
is like Kiki Palmer like how are you in
a relationship again after you're not
like I don't think no I would never
trust someone
if I were him put me on blast this is it
like no we're not in a relationship
anymore yeah I agree this feels like
none of our business it feels weird to
even comment on it but like she put it
out there and just I feel like we don't
know a lot about her relationship so
everybody's like really leaning into
these text messages for like different
context clues and based on things I
think we can like infer from the text
message it doesn't seem like he's out
here being like you big like it
seems like I don't know it seems like if
you're concerned no not only that it
seems like if you're gonna talk about
weight with your partner which is a
decision either you talk about it or you
don't you don't have to talk about it
but it seems like if you are going to
talk about it he's someone who's talking
about it and kind of like a healthy way
right
I I didn't see I didn't read this and be
like this guy my initial reaction was
like based on headlines I'm like oh this
but if you take the time to
read it
it's not that bad no he said like I said
you're so beautiful and I love you and I
always will think you're beautiful
it's not like he's saying like you
changed and I'm not attracted to you
right and so she's actually she's asking
did I change she said yes but you're
still beautiful to me yeah and I kind of
relate to Bebe rexha and being like I've
had this where I'm like to Ben like I
feel so disgusting like I really am so
unhappy like I hit a wall I feel like a
lot of people get there like you know
your weight doesn't bother you and then
it does and it's like all you can think
about and I've said to Ben like I'm
really unhappy and he's like okay well
you know let's do something together
like let's join a gym or and like his
like that response makes me mad I'm like
no like you just wanted to
complain yeah yeah so like I actually
can understand Bebe Rex said but like I
do not understand blasting it on social
media would you ever put just Bonds on
Instagram no because then I'm giving
other people on the internet free reign
to talk about my body yeah
it's weird sitting here talking about BB
Rex's 35 pound waking but like she put
it
she served me up Jackie and now we've
said it yeah
and you know this is actually very
pertinent because we have a deer
toasters about this exact issue
oh interesting yes I'm interested to
hear what you have to say but also Bebe
rexa has spoken about her weight gain in
the last few weeks I think she was on
like the Jennifer Hudson show she also
shared that she has PCOS so it's just
been like a transitional time for her
but there was no com like further
commentary like we didn't talk it's not
a story Bebe rexha no says she's gained
weight but also I felt like when I did
hear or see headlines about her talking
about it like it was in a very
um
matter of fact no like in a self-assured
way like I've gained weight look like it
doesn't bother me and I'm still living
my best life yeah yeah as you said
sometimes it's a sign of just like
contentment and like yeah I think that
was like Courtney was saying that
Kourtney Kardashian a few episodes ago
how like when she's super skinny it
means she's not happy and if she's like
if she's
um a little
heavier like it just means that she's
happy and content and not so like yeah
and it's not it's not like a blanky
Universal thing like if you're fat
you're unhappy like I think everybody's
different like I think when people some
people you know are at their fittest
it's a sign of them being at their best
and I think sometimes like Courtney it's
a sign of like you know true contentment
not needing to keep up with anything
relaxation yes that's so it's not one or
it's not one or the other for everyone
so that's why you just shouldn't talk
about it because you don't know if
somebody's like dealing with something
really tragic and stressful so just
don't talk about it but in a
relationship that's where you share your
deepest and darkest and most vulnerable
at truths so that's fine but to put it
online girl leave us out of it I want no
part of this no and in a relationship
like you should know if your partner
like is in a good place or a bad place
duh yeah
this is weird like very weird yeah this
trend of like celebrities putting their
person not here for text messages and
thoughts and feelings about their
current Partners I'm not here for it no
it's so not celebrity no like some
things can be private girl like keep it
yourself yeah are you ready for our next
story I really truly am finally after a
day's delay Lindsay Lohan gives birth
and welcomes her first baby with her
husband Bader Shamus so the actress has
given birth to her and her husband's
first child a son named Louie a rep for
Lohan tells page six it's spelled
l-u-a-i
maybe it's like lie
lie Lou luau Lu I
okay pretty she said the rep said the
family is over the moon in love the baby
was born in Dubai where the couple lives
although his exact birthday was not
immediately made known
I'm really happy for Lindsay I think you
know
that generation of girls
Amanda Bynes Lindsay Lohan uh Brittany
a really now coming out of like their
trauma like they were like treated so
poorly I think they went through so much
and so to see Lindsay come out on the
other side she's acting again she's
happily married she's kind of like a
traditional chewy girl like getting
married and then having babies like I'm
so happy for her like I really she's
someone I don't think of often but when
I do I wish her well yeah and I feel
like after a lot of years of
being mysterious who knows what she's
been up to some weird videos and it's
not like in the last few she's really
like gotten her life together and
settled down in her career as she's
acting again she did that Netflix movie
she's married she's having baby like I
think it's really nice
I think so too although I do you know
often think about you know that era of
her life where she was running around
London on Instagram live like right
chasing down Syrian Refuge refugees in
the street yeah but that was also at the
same time when she was doing that MTV
show Lohan Beach Club Beach which was
actually crazy but if you watch the show
she was like totally fine like the way
that like you think of her like or we
all saw that video of her dancing in
Mykonos that like went so viral and
you're like yeah what's going on with
Lindsay but then when you watch the show
like she's literally running her
business and she's totally fine and she
was like level-headed yeah
okay good I really like we she raised us
I wish her the best and I think
motherhood already looks great on her I
hope she's you know just nesting I truly
wish her well me too she also like
Amanda Bynes is an amazing actress yeah
extreme Talent like an extreme talent
and we are at a loss like without her
doing more movies and I just I hope she
does more movies because she's really
such a great actress I agree I mean of
course you know the greats come to mind
Confessions of a Teenage Drama Queen
Mean Girls Freaky Friday not enough
people talk about Herbie Fully Loaded
George you're rule your favorite movie
Georgia rule oh my God I literally
Georgia rule is now one of those movies
that gets clipped on Tick Tock and like
it's reaching a whole new generation
people in the comments being like what
movie is this
um and it's that scene where like
Felicity Huffman finally comes down to
Jane Fonda's house and it's like tell me
the truth what really happened with my
new man and it's chilling and I'm so
glad a younger generation is is seeing
it it's it's Felicity Huffman Jane Fonda
and Garrett Hedlund and Lindsay Lohan's
finest work
I need to watch that movie again yeah
you do so anyways I'm really happy for
her me too Mazel Tov to you
are you ready for our fifth and final
Story another Mazel Tov is in order no
because our fifth and final story where
another Mazel Tov is in order it's
brought to you by Quince summer is here
and your wardrobe no offense it needs an
upgrade instead of a flimsy fast fashion
haul spend your money wisely on high
quality Essentials that will last beyond
this season Quince is our spot for quiet
luxury without paying luxury prices
so Quinn's offers a range of must-have
items like 100 European linen um for
under 50 luxurious Mulberry silk skirts
and of course Italian leather bags and
14 karat gold jewelry from thirty
dollars all of their prices are 50 to 80
less than similar Brands and that's
because Quinn's has Timeless classic
styles that will not go out of fashion
and you'll have them in your closet
forever I have so many like I've been
saying this like I'm trying to build
like a capsule wardrobe where I have
different Basics that are all really
high quality that I can live with for
many years and just wear differently in
style differently so I have a great pair
of black slacks from Quinn's I have a
great cashmere sweater from Queens I
have a great cardigan from Quince
they're really classic Timeless pieces
and the way that they're able to do
their pricing is they partner directly
with top factories to cut out the cost
of the middleman and pass the savings on
to you what's even better is that Quince
only works with factories that use safe
ethical and responsible manufacturing
practices and premium eco-friendly
fabrics and finishes so we can feel good
about getting high quality items that
last longer upgrade your closet this
summer with quince right now go to
quince.com toast to get free shipping
and a 365 day return on your next order
that's
quince.com toast for free shipping and
365 day returns quince.com toast today's
episode is also brought to you by
impossible Foods it is summertime it
means it's Hot Grill summer
and we're all outside you know being
girly barbecuing up and impossible Foods
once you and your grill to join them in
making meat history so as you may or may
not know impossible beef is delicious it
tastes like beef and historically
speaking of course beef is delicious no
but it's made from plants so impossible
has zero animal hormones 19 grams of
protein per serving and it's better for
the planet it's so delicious it tastes
just like beef so why not the next time
you're shopping at your local grocer
grab impossible beef patties grab any of
the impossible food products they're so
good they're good for the planet they
have a ton of protein and you know
you're you're doing good for your body
good for the planet while also
participating in barbecue culture
because it's barbecue season you know us
vegetarian girls our kosher girls or
girls who want to eat less meat like we
don't want to be left out we still want
to wear cute outfits and Grill it up so
if you're looking for better options on
what to grill grab impossible
we're making meat history today head
over to the meat aisle at your local
store grab some impossible beef patties
and get grilling Jackie and I Jackie
more so because you know we're Limited
in what we can eat as kosher girlies we
find ourselves over the last few years
really always reaching for the
impossible aisle when there's impossible
burgers at restaurants like we're always
ordering it's such a treat it's such a
luxury
um and you should join us because
there's no reason not to it's so
delicious it tastes just like beef but
it's so much better for the planet so
this summer make sure to head over to
the local grocer get yourself some
impossible beef
thanks Claude you're welcome our fifth
and final story Mazel Tov is in order to
Dylan Sprouse and Barbara Palvin yes
they got married in Hungary one month
after announcing their engagement the
Stars said I do during a secret ceremony
in the model's home country of Hungary
over the weekend a local Outlet claimed
that the nuptials took place in a church
just outside the Hungarian capital of
Budapest and Vogue has all the photos so
first the local Outlet bores online how
to take photos of the Bride who looked
how cute in her corset style wedding
gown and sheer gloves and then the Vogue
exclusive dropped and the photos are
just gorgeous
yeah this was so um unexpected like
obviously I knew that they were engaged
but they had a relatively like normal
length engagement for like a celebrity
and I didn't know she was Hungarian I
love that they all flew to Hungary like
to celebrate her culture this is so cute
I love these two these are one of my
favorite celebrity couples and they're
not so obvious you know they're not in
your face they're just like seem really
happy and I love them I love Barbara
Palvin I love Dylan's brows like I'm
obsessed I'm obsessed they've been
together for a long time they seem so
suited for one another I'm glad they're
married and I loved her wedding look
like I feel like it was very traditional
but also something about it was
incredibly like unique and not what
we've seen before we've gotten some
really good Bridal looks in the last
like year I feel no the the models are
doing the most for the bridal industry
Taylor Hill Kate Bach Palvin yep yep I
mean I guess that's you know why they're
paid
no and that's why like
they literally model wedding dresses
because they're models you know yeah she
looks like she's in the campaign like
it's just too easy
she's really beautiful I really
um she's one of my favorite models you
know weirdly and I love Dylan's brows
he's definitely my favorite Sprouse twin
my fellow and my NYU Alum oh wow he's
your favorite Sprouse
I would say so would you not agree
as much as like Dylan he seems like the
more affable unserious brother who like
you'd actually want to hang out with I
just feel like that's because we also
don't know as much about him as we do
about coal because he's kind of like
everywhere and he takes himself so
seriously well I feel like you know they
were these young child stars together
and then they definitely took a break I
know they went to college because I went
to college with them
um and then Cole had this Resurgence
with Riverdale the biggest show and it
was like Cole Sprouse Cole Sprouse and
then he dated Lily Reinhardt I feel like
it was so much coal that Dylan got left
behind and then very slowly everybody
started to just like take their own
interest in Dylan do in large part to
him being in like this fabulous
seemingly really normal healthy
relationship and I feel like he's gotten
his moment even though Cole is like the
obvious one now he's the more famous One
um but like when Barbara was at the
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show and Dylan
was sitting front row like being so
proud of his girly like I'm obsessed
have they ever gone to the Met Gala yes
together yes I'm on my way
they do they really are like low-key
like a socialite couple you know yeah
they are they're not like so obvious
they're not getting hounded by Paparazzi
they probably have a very normal life
where they you know probably live nice
you know they make a lot of money from I
know she's like a big model for a lot of
big Brands but they they have a sense of
normalcy which we love yeah we do and
Cole
was his best man it seems oh that's so
sweet yeah they had this big bachelor
party I think in Iceland
um it's nice it's really nice though
getting the exclusive we love it yeah
she wore Vivian Westwood
stunning yeah really pretty dress so
those were the fast five stories and I
feel as though you needed to know them
you did you def you definitely did and
I'm excited because we have deer
toasters the one I was referring to is
up first so if you want to submit your
toasters it is our weekly advice segment
we do it every Wednesday or we try to do
it every Wednesday sometimes it gets
pushed to Thursday just depending on
this are up to programming thing yes
um but if you want to write in it's
always done completely anonymously you
can submit two ways the first is just
emailing us at deertoesters gmail.com or
head over to the toastpodcast.com we
have a submission box again totally
Anonymous right right hand girls what's
going on
um okay ready yep
hey Jackson Claude love the podcast
here's my issue I've been with my
husband for almost seven years we have
two kids together and we just got
married six months ago after on our
honeymoon we were literally in the
middle of having sex when he says I know
that you're bigger than most girls but
you're so sexy
I know how he meant it but seriously I
immediately got up I went into the
bathroom and I cried I am a little bit
of a bigger girl I always have been my
entire relationship I I thought that he
was the one person who never saw my
weight he's never once commented on it
or made any comments about it based you
know how much I eat the gym Etc and
that's why I love him I thought he saw
me for who I am needless to say this
incident has me up to my core am
I just overthinking this is this a
stupid guy thing when I finally got the
courage to tell him about it he was
extremely apologetic so reassuring that
it was a stupid comment we were also a
little drunk but for some reason I just
can't get over it it stuck with me and
has been bothering me so much so much
lately should I just get over it am I
being dramatic thanks love you both I
don't think that you're being dramatic
like you're entitled to your feelings
and sometimes something hits you
sideways even when I think it's so
clear that like he meant it in the
kindest way like he thought he was
saying something nice and he didn't
realize he just like ruined your whole
trip
um I think that we can forgive him yeah
I'm glad that you like told him that it
bothered you uh and it you have every
right to like be bothered by it but he
really meant it in a nice way and I
would try and focus on like the positive
half of the statement because that's
what really matters
yeah also just like people say crazy
things in sex like you also have to
chalk it up to like dirty talk like
people just say things like that's like
Amy Schumer does a bit where she's like
when you start having sex with your
husband he says all these crazy things
like you know he doesn't mean he's like
oh yeah let's get let's so hard and
like we're not gonna so hard you're
literally my family you know it's really
funny
um but I think this is a really
interesting thing as somebody who's been
about their whole life like
you really want like
like it's it's kind of like a
a fact of no what's what I'm looking for
it's like it's a very matter of fact
thing like I know that I'm fat you know
but the way like somebody says it even
in a complimentary way which is was it
kind of just like bursts your bubble
that nobody sees that about you and it's
really tough because you think you know
for me at least like I was always you
know doing the most like hair makeup
personality like just to deflect from
the fact that I'm bigger than most
people and for somebody to even not
whether it's in a positive or negative
way to even acknowledge it to your face
is like so disgusting you know even
though it's not bad or good I feel like
fat has become like a a bad word but
it's just you know it's a fact like I I
was fat it's like numbers yeah so for
for somebody to bring it up to you
that's the most towering part because it
bursts the bubble that you have
successfully been like deflecting people
from noticing you know yes no I I
understand completely and I understand
why she's upset by it
but the but you don't have to be you
don't have to be in the takeaways like
that he's obsessed with you he loves you
two kids seven years like
you guys are great
and he meant he was trying to pay you a
compliment like men yeah and he was
trying to make it yeah yeah and you know
what maybe that's like you know a
subconscious way of him wanting to you
to like lean into like your Curvy Girl
life you know he's into it and some
women like wear it as a badge of honor
and are so good about being confident
and some people it just destroys their
confidence until they can you know get
it under control but maybe he wants you
to be that type of and that's
complimentary or he's or he so like
thinks of you as someone who's extremely
like confident in your size and that
that would not affect you at all like
maybe yeah you're putting on this like
front that like and not even a front but
as you know for a lot of people he's
been who you are and yeah he saw it as
like you know he's paying you a
compliment to like how confident you are
no and just
back to what you said for a lot of big
girls like they're so confident and for
a lot of them myself included like it's
a facade it's just a way of getting
ahead of of anything
yeah but I'm sorry that happened
so sweet yeah he sounds like a good man
sounds like it was really just people
say crazy things in the bedroom he was
like trying to like come up with like a
a fresh compliment you know that's like
yeah just like oh you're so beautiful
yeah it's like that episode of sex and
city where Charlotte has sex with that
guy and every time they have sex he says
like the craziest like degrading
and she's like this you know nice Upper
East Side wasp and so you just chalk it
up to like pillow talk you know yeah
it's a little different but I understand
okay ready for our next one
yes I have a few that I'm like I I have
a bunch which one
oh that's new no I always take a bunch
no okay I'm gonna do this one
hey girlies been a listener forever and
I appreciate the years of Giggles my
father-in-law said something to me that
I truly can't get over long story short
he took a picture of me and my husband
and when seeing the picture I commented
just to my husband that my boobs looked
so big in the photo my father-in-law
overheard me and he said I could hold
them for you if you want obviously
referring to my boobs that grossed me
out my husband told him later when I
wasn't around that the comment was
inappropriate but both my father-in-law
and my mother-in-law didn't see issue
with it so the comment was just swept on
the under the rug but I feel weirdly
objectified whenever I see my
father-in-law I don't see him regularly
but when I do it's for days at a time am
I being dramatic that I can't not think
about that creepy comment whenever he's
around
it's literally the weirdest thing ever
and to be honest there's nothing you
could do about it because the one thing
you could do I would have told you your
husband has to tell your father that
that was inappropriate and he did it so
there's quite literally nothing you can
do but we're here to um corroborate that
is literally so weird and
inappropriate and I guess we gotta chop
this up to like you know the elderly
yeah the elderly not everyone can be
Jerry from the golden Bachelor the
Elder's gonna Elder and this is one of
them things that you just gotta swallow
but like we are here for you it's
weird and inappropriate yeah and
just like stay away from him like try
not to have conversations with him where
you're gonna hear more weird that
you don't want to hear and it's just
like you know like you gotta Dodge him
yeah by the way yeah and
now that you know he's a freak like a
comment to your husband being like Oh my
boobs look so big
just don't say it yeah no I wouldn't
talk about like things that might rile
him up and I'm not in any way saying you
provoked him to say that no no but you
know he's a freak so
try your absolute best and not to even
give him like an inch or of space to say
something like that yeah but Elder's
gonna Elder and in-law's gonna in-law
elder-in-laws gonna elder-in-law and I'm
proud of you for taking you know in-law
Dynamics are very sensitive and you knew
immediately it was on your husband to
say something and I'm proud of you for
doing that I'm sorry it didn't work out
the way you wanted it to yeah
but you just oh there's gonna help
people at a certain point it's so true
like I don't know how old this man is
but if he's your father-in-law and your
toaster he has to be at least 60 and
they're so far gone change like don't
even bother just put your energy towards
your business or something yeah yeah I
agree okay our third and final is an
update so we had a girly write in I'll
read you a little bit of a synopsis from
what she wrote in she said her boyfriend
over a year um has been really
supportive in her getting off of birth
control but her hormones have been
really crazy she feels really repulsed
by him like him farting puts her over
the edge I feel like he's lazy he's
gross he's annoying and before birth
control I was madly in love of course
with the occasional annoyance but she
doesn't know if like her honeymoon faces
ended if it's hormones she doesn't know
so we had basically told her like you
got to give it time like your body is
out of whack like not enough people talk
about how like birth control really
changes you and there have been studies
done done on all this so we told her to
just like chill and if in due time she's
still repulsed by this man maybe it's
just the relationship not the birth
control all no maybe it was the birth
control that made her attracted to him
but like once she's leveled out and
she's completely like feeling herself
and not hormonal and
up and down then she can make a decision
but like don't make a decision right now
while you're still like coming down off
of everything so here's her update turdy
Lou and Jackie oh I wanted to send you
an update on my hormone Fiasco and by
the way I like that we always complain
that people don't give us updates but
like this girl we needed months and she
literally wrote in months ago so yeah I
feel like it's an adequate update I
wanted to send you an update on my
hormone Fiasco I followed your advice of
giving my body time to get back in order
before doing anything rash and I'm so
happy I did because we are back to
normal my hormones were honestly whack
and it's crazy what my body went through
he has been very patient with me and
made me realize he's a total P John I'm
never getting back on that again
and we are now taking steps to embrace
our fertility Journey I'm very excited
to start a family with him and I'm so
grateful I took your advice side note it
took me about six months to feel normal
again and that is just crazy that is
crazy that's a really good lesson for
everyone if anybody's feeling this way
coming off of birth control like there's
so many different things that you deal
with when you come off of birth control
but if one of them is like your
personality has changed you're
attractiveness to your partner has
changed like give it time not saying it
well maybe you know maybe it won't
bounce back but it could and you just
have to like give things time because
these hormones Run Deep yeah that's why
we were saying at the beginning of the
episode like listening to your body like
being acutely aware of what your body's
going through because maybe you know a
girl is going through this not realizing
it has anything to do with her going off
birth control and then she breaks up
with her boyfriend who might have been
the one for her yeah
so this is a lesson and I'm grateful she
gave us time too six months that's
that's a half a year yeah no and I'm
glad that it's reached such a positive
conclusion yeah and I wish her luck on
her journey on fertility I'd love to
hear from you maybe in another six
months maybe are you pregnant like let
us know yeah keep us posted stay in
touch and for stay in touch and thank
you for writing in an update so many of
our girlies forget about us they take
our amazing advice and then they live
their fabulous lives forgetting where
they came from
it's true it's true it's a good sign but
please write us an update on whatever it
is you wrote in about and of course if
you just want to write in that's
deertoesters gmail.com or the
toastpodcast.com thank you guys so much
for a great episode Jax thank you for
your time and
apparently Stitcher is shutting down oh
you know I heard about that I'm gonna
have to change my outro
just something the podcast the thing is
the podcast landscape is constantly
shifting and we have to do our best to
say the outro is constantly shifting
love ya